Donald Trump has I think the best way to
describe it is Donald Trump to use a
poker term was on tilt in the middle of
the night a couple of days ago clearly
Donald Trump's atrocious and abortive
debate performance has been affecting
him first he started denying provable
truths during the debate then after the
debate he denied the denials and he also
denied some of the statements he made
during that debate and then now we have
learned that Donald Trump went on a
completely bizarre and unhinged rant in
the middle of the night about a sex tape
a sex tape a presidential candidate at
5:00 in the morning tweeting about a sex
tape
he first tweeted to his supporters or
his detractors or whoever follows the
guy on Twitter at about 3:20 in the
morning eastern time and I'll show you
this tweet saying do not believe media
reports that are using the phrase
sources said there are no sources they
are just made up lies two hours later at
5:30 a.m. in the morning Donald Trump
went on just a ridiculous Twitter rant
about the former Miss Universe winner
who he fat shamed by calling her Miss
Piggy and whose heritage he denigrated
by calling her Miss Housekeeping were of
course here talking about Alicia Machado
who is very clearly on record about the
disgusting ways in which Donald Trump
allegedly treated her how his attacks on
her led to her developing an eating
disorder etc and Donald Trump putting
out a tweet here which I will also show
you saying did crooked Hillary help
disgusting check out sex tape and past
Alicia em become a US citizen
so she could use her in the debate it's
not that common for presidential
candidates to recommend people look at
sex tapes on Twitter in the middle of
the night now whether or not this
alleged sex tape exists is it irrelevant
it does a
to be false Alisha Machado appeared in a
sort of risque scene on a reality
television show there doesn't appear to
be any sex tape that's not really the
point right the real point is that this
is disgusting even many Republicans I'll
show you a tweet by notable Republican
strategist Anna Navarro who said Trump's
gone from erratic to unhinged from
vulgar to gross
from unfit to be President to unfit to
be called sane does anybody else see a
pattern here when Donald Trump is alone
and allowed to just think and tweet we
see the real Trump right we see the
self-destructive Trump this is evidence
that Donald Trump is clearly unfit to be
President but as I've said before this
continues to reinforce and knee the idea
but on some level Donald Trump does not
want to be President this is a pattern
remember when around midnight one night
during the primary campaign he posted
this unflattering picture of Heidi Cruz
the wife of then Republican rival Ted
Cruz these are not presidential actions
these are not logical actions for a 70
year old man to be participating in this
is a 13 year old in the body of a
seven-year-old who somehow is going to
end up being at worst missing the
presidency by a few million votes Newt
Gingrich somehow the voice of reason in
this entire thing I'll put up a tweet a
quote rather from Newt Gingrich who said
you can't tweet at 3:00 in the morning
period there's no excuse ever not if
you're going to be President of the
United States so he's really got to
decide if he's got to be himself that he
may well not win if he's willing to grow
into the role of president then he may
win when Newt Gingrich is sounding
reasonable when Newt Gingrich is the
voice of reason you know that you're off
the deep end and some people are getting
it some people are saying you know
Hillary Clinton yeah I disagree with her
on a lot of policy I don't like this or
that that she's done in terms of
cronyism and and sort of the deep
destructive nature of how politics are
funded I don't like it but
Donald Trump is tweeting about sex tapes
at 5:00 a.m. this is not a man who can
be president of the u.s. period I hope
it's enough to keep Trump out of the
White House
it may not be many of our viewers and
listeners know that just posting your
job listing on one website isn't enough
to find quality candidates if you want
to find the perfect hire you really need
to post your job on all the top job
sites and now you can with zip recruiter
dot-com you can post your job to 100
plus job sites including social media
networks like Facebook and Twitter all
with a single click you can find
candidates in any city any industry
nationwide just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll in to zip
recruiters easy to use interface no
juggling emails no juggling calls to
your office you can quickly screen
candidates rate them and hire the right
person quickly find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by over a
million businesses and right now David
Pakman show listeners can post jobs on
zip recruiter for free by going to zip
recruiter dot-com slash free trial that
is zip recruiter dot-com slash free
trial one more time try it for free at
zip recruiter dot-com slash free trial